قرار المشترك ما بين البلدين بعوده
العلاقات القنصليه الى حالتها الطبيعيه
ومنه همم عوده همم منح تاشيرات همم الى
شكلها الطبيعي وهو ما حدث مع همم المغرب
ايضا في نفس التوقيت وهمم
بالتجامل مع احد ما يحدث في الجزائر لانه
لا يمكن ان ربيته فقط بالجزائر وان كان
الامر شكلي همم
هون مسالتها
لانه الامر همم اكبر همم من ذلك همم فرنسا
اعتقد الان همم شيء ما بين تبحث عن طرق
لتودد الى الجزائر همم همم من اجل محاوله
العوده
وسد الفراغ واستدراك ربما اخطاء همم همم
الماضي في المنافسه الدوليه بعد زياره
وزير خارجيه تركيا على سبيل المثال قبل
يومين او ثلاث فقط
ومحاوله تركيا رفع الاستثمارات من خمسه
الى عشره مليارات دولار همم اعلان
الامريكي عن قمه جزائريه امريكيه في همم
23 حول مكافحه الارهاب اذن فرنسا ربما
سالت اين هي من كل هذا لذلك همم البحث عن
الاستدراك ربما ما فاتها خلال العهد
الاولى على الاقل لايمانيا